[Música]
me gustaría que levante la mano quien de
aquí tiene una empresa
perfecto ustedes estoy seguro que les va
a interesar lo que voy a venir
platicando durante los siguientes
minutos y los otros que no levantaron la
mano también porque estoy muy seguro que
en su mente quieren en un futuro poner
un negocio
durante los siguientes minutos vamos a
ver las cuatro características que
tienen empresas como disney
netflix google que ustedes pueden
aplicar en sus negocios para lograr
objetivos extraordinarios ahora necesito
que ahora por favor levanten la mano las
personas que se han sentido así después
de haber fracasado en algún proyecto
levanten la mano
es horrendo no es feo le ponen mucho
empeño le ponen mucho corazón trabajas
incluso mucho dinero en algunas
ocasiones porque todo apuestas a ese
proyecto y las cosas no salen como tú
quisieras
este sentimiento
no es único de ustedes también lo he
sentido yo
estas fotos del 2014 en el 2014 cierro
esta empresa después de seis meses de
estar abierta ni siquiera alcance un
promedio
de coros o de tiempo soy licencia del
mercado e imagínense todas las preguntas
que me hice sobre por qué fracasó este
proyecto pero algo que es muy importante
de esa foto que le pedí no recuerdo a
quién le pedí que me la tomara para
tener esta imagen muy clara sobre mi
cabeza es que también en 2014 tenía una
cuenta con la cual estamos cada vez
asesorando y crecía y crecía y creciente
porque carajos con este cliente puedo
lograr estos estos objetivos y porque
con mi propia empresa no fue entonces
cuando empecé a preguntarme que tenía
esa empresa y las grandes marcas en
común que yo podía empezar a imitar para
poder lograr objetivos cada vez mejores
les voy a contar dos datos que son un
poco abrumador es uno de ahorita y otro
que viene en 10 años el primero
es el financiero un medio importante de
nuestro país aquí en méxico y hace algún
tiempo llegó a la información
mi computador buscando datos sobre cuál
era el índice de mortalidad de las
empresas en nuestro país y no nada más
me regaló el índice de mortalidad de
nuestro país sino que me regaló una
comparativa con países como brasil eeuu
y colombia
en eeuu y en brasil
por cada 10 empresas solamente fracasan
antes del segundo año 3.5 empresas
en colombia son seis empresas las que
fracasan antes del segundo año de cada
diez empresas en mexico como creen que
ande
ya se asustaron verdad lo deja el último
porque el méxico dependiendo de la
fuente en esta en esta en este medio
marca que 7.5 empresas de cada día
fracasa antes del segundo año en nuestro
país
otro dato que abruma también es que hace
unos días revisando otra vez buscando
datos me gustan mucho los datos en una
nota de expansión en alianza con cnn
hablan de que el 50 por ciento de los
trabajos que hoy existen van a
desaparecer para el 2030
50% de los trabajos que hoy tenemos van
a desaparecer para el 2030 esto que va a
ocasionar que muchas personas van a
emprender y van a querer generar una
empresa y van a querer construir una
marca porque no van a tener opción
porque allá afuera no están las
condiciones para emplear a tantos
graduados de una carrera profesional
en mi profesión me dedico a la
construcción de marcas y creo que muchas
respuestas están ahí
porque las marcas porque construir una
marca te ayuda a pensar que es todo lo
que vas a diseñar de forma diferente
para competir y obviamente tener
excelentes resultados
la marca es eso que te va a ser único
eso que podemos poner el ejemplo ahorita
con ustedes de por qué yo no tengo pelo
y ustedes si eso que nos va marcando
porque la señorita de ella tiene el pelo
morado eso te hace diferente eso es tu
marca incluso existe todo el concepto de
marca personal pero el tema aquí es
quién además hay que generar marcas sino
que hay que generar marcas
extraordinarias
lo tibio lo promedio es más ser bueno
hoy ya no es suficiente
hoy necesita ser extraordinario que si
no lo haces estás en serios problemas
porque hay tanta gente buena allá afuera
que ya el margen de poder ser exitoso
cada vez se reduce más hoy construir una
marca extraordinaria no es un tema de
sobresalir es un tema de sobrevivir que
tienen estas grandes marcas en su adn
que nos pueden ayudar a aterrizar esos
conceptos y aplicarlos a todas las
empresas que existen y por eso fue que
después de algunos fracasos en algunos
emprendimientos y de dedicarme a la
consultoría en el área fue que empecé a
analizar y analizar analizar qué era lo
que necesitábamos obtener de ahí y fue
cuando se me ocurrió la idea de abstraer
los cuatro conceptos a cuatro
características y ahí fue cuando nació
el diamante de marcas extraordinarias si
algo quiero que se lleven ustedes el día
de hoy es el diamante de marcas
extraordinarias así que no olviden que
fracasé a enel como un hit pero quiero
que se lleven este concepto porque va a
ser
gran ayuda y aparte lo pensé en que los
conceptos de marketing muchas veces la
media no los entienden y necesitamos
adaptarlos para que todos puedan
entenderlos y sobre todo aplicar los
cuales la primera característica y vamos
a hacer examen al ratito cuál es la
primera característica de una marca
extraordinaria el ser extraordinario y
van a decir bueno eso es una lógico sí
pero a veces se olvidan porque hay
cuatro elementos
que llevan a esta característica del ser
extraordinario y esos cuatro elementos
son estos ser extraordinario en la
calidad ser extraordinario en la
estructura ser extraordinario en la
innovación y ser extraordinario en la
intención
por ejemplo me encantan las hamburguesas
creo que se nota
y si ponemos el ejemplo de la
hamburguesa y nos referimos a calidad
que sería excelente lechuga excelente
pan excelente carne excelente
restaurantes el tema de estructura tener
un establecimiento sumamente bien
logrado procesos manuales en el tema de
la innovación una marca que a mí me
fascina es la marca de carl june yo
entiendo el mercado local no sé qué
tiene de local o de local
pero nos vendió la idea se adaptó al
mercado de las personas que estaban
queriendo cuidar su imagen y luego yo el
siguiente paso y meter la carne
vegetariana viable y entonces atiende
todo este segmento de los vegetarianos y
está entendiendo y algo que no se nos
puede olvidar es el tema de la intención
las marcas extraordinarias
tienen forzosamente que tener personas
extraordinarias atrás si se nos olvide
el tema de los valores del cómo voy a
impactar a mi entorno a mi equipo y a
los clientes entonces algo no estamos
haciendo del todo extraordinario esta es
la primera característica de una marca
extraordinaria el ser el segundo es el
parecer parecer extraordinario aquí
necesitamos fijarnos y poner mucha
atención en el cómo nos comunicamos y
cómo nos presentamos les va a sonar muy
conocido está esta anécdota de bolita
que de repente sea en tu tío era
extraordinario en los años 80 si no
necesitaba promocionarse solito le
llegaban los clientes hoy los clientes
no llegan solitos
hoy necesitas forzosamente también
echarle ganas concéntrate en el tema del
diseño y la comunicación en cómo me
comunico y en el cómo me presento es
fundamental si quieres construir una
marca extraordinaria
volviendo al tema de las hamburguesas si
ustedes llegan y de repente me imagino
conocen algunas cadenas que les ofrecen
publicidad con hamburguesas que parecen
del tamaño del edificio más grande del
mundo y cuando llegas te cabe en la
palma de la mano apenas al centro esos
señores es porque también tenemos que
cuidar la congruencia solamente cuando
se es extraordinario y parece es
extraordinario se cumplen las dos
características eres congruente y
solamente cuando eres congruente es que
aparece la tercera característica que es
la característica del validar
actualmente necesitan las marcas
extraordinarias estarse validando
internamente y externamente internamente
tienes que tener empleados que estén
felices
tienes que validar que estén feliz
nuevos que mis empleados están súper
felices pues pregúntales
hace un examen de clima un estudio de
clima
hoy es algo en lo que los empresario les
va a encantar este concepto las ventas
claro algo que nos valida de una marca
accionarias que tiene que ser rentable
yo podemos estarle teniendo miedo a la
rentabilidad y mucho menos a la riqueza
entre más recursos podamos generar más
podemos ayudar a la gente allá afuera a
nuestros colaboradores
y en la parte exterior que funciona pues
los rankings los tops top 5 top 10 el
recibirán hong hizo de la mejor tiene un
excelente socio comercial e imagínate
qué tan importante es el tema de la
validación que hay empresas que están
dispuestas a pagar por aparecer en un
ranking qué tan importante es validar tu
marca que hay personas que pagan para
aparecer en algún lugar
esta es la tercera ser
y perdurar es lo que todo no queremos
todo queremos perdurar yo no conozco y
no creo que nadie aquí de repente me
diga hoy un andar en siete venas es
ahora me lo voy a invertir 200 mil pesos
al negocio y como en tres años pondré en
riesgo mi patrimonio y voy a fracasar
yo creo que como en tres años fracaso
pagar algún psicólogo y ver a cabo
después de mi vida con el riesgo de que
mi esposa y mis hijos me abandonan
[Música]
nadie piensa así todo el mundo quiere
perdonar pero si se fijan el perdurar el
resultado de estarte validando está
pareciendo extraordinario y sobre todo
ser extraordinario es una consecuencia
de todo lo anterior y el perdurar es
estar en el mercado de forma
ventajosa
con liderazgo impactando de forma
positiva a tus clientes internos y
externos a las personas que están en tu
comunidad perdurar en un tiempo que la
gente diga mira ya lleva diez años ya
lleva 15 años en el mercado genera
confianza estamos de acuerdo
si llegas con un abogado y le dices oye
cuando te grabaste hace seis meses dice
no sé si hay un abogado y de repente
tengo 20 años de experiencia en lo que
necesitas
por supuesto que vas a confiar este es
el modelo del diamante de marcas extra
dinerarias que desarrollamos con mucho
cariño para que las empresas pudieran
aplicar la sre
perfecto con eso yo me quedo muy feliz
el día de hoy y es un tema de dinero
chicos aunque ser netflix tengo que
hacer
google tengo que hacer disney para poder
ser una madre extraordinaria aunque
tiene mucho dinero para poder generar
experiencias extraordinarias la
respuesta es por supuesto que no es un
tema de voluntad es un tema que
necesitas forzosamente solamente
planearlo en tu cabeza no cuesta muchas
veces y les voy a poner el siguiente
ejemplo que me encanta es una escrita
dice que tienen hambre tranquilos
nacionalmente conocido ok y este señor
es un señor que está por la casa de mi
madre y se le juntaba de tal manera las
personas que se ponían nerviosos y los
comensales empezaban a molestar porque
clásico que llega el abusivo que se mete
y le dice ella mejor pues es pero
típicamente es más guapo es más afín al
lotero y le dice primero la cigüeña y el
gordito y alegó que fue lo que hizo este
señor este señor no tenía philip kotler
no tenía a simmons inec no tenía a quien
más a cualquier gurú de la mercadotecnia
y de la innovación no lo tenía el señor
solamente observó y tuvo la voluntad no
gastó más que centavos y le dio una
experiencia diferente a la gente les
entregó boletos
un carrito de elotes entregó políticos
ese dinero
por supuesto que no es de dinero es un
tema de voluntad si quiere ser una marca
extra en área estás poniendo como
pretexto el tema del presupuesto ya
empezamos mal
[Música]
con esto cerramos la pinza del ser
parecer validar ya perdonar que forman
parte de las cuatro características de
marcas extraordinarias pero hay un truco
que le pasó a coda que le pasó a pensaba
así a muchas empresas que han fracasado
quien no se vuelven a preguntar se
duermen en los laureles cuando verduras
te quedas dormido y su single ya no
necesito moverme ya no necesito buscar
nuevas respuestas sonoras preguntas y
esta flecha significa que tenemos
determinado cada determinado tiempo
dependiendo la industria que preguntarte
sigo siendo extraordinario
sigo siendo extraordinario sigue
pareciendo extraordinario lo que me ha
valido en aquel entonces me está
validando ahorita sí o no y hay dos
valores que forman parte del diamante de
marcas extraordinarias uno es el de la
congruencia y dos es el tema de la
persistencia cualquier marca persona
empresa que sea congruente y persistente
con el tiempo
por ser una marca extraordinaria este es
el casete de mi padre en los años 90s
aquí lo traigo y porque me encanta y me
apasiona hablar de este tema porque en
aquel entonces cuando tenía como 78 años
y tuve mi primera publicación con ese
muñequito que era mi interpretación me
tapa
desde esa época me encanta todo esto
el segundo porque cuando tuve la
oportunidad de poner mi primer negocio
en forma fue este no sólo un carrito
hamburguesas y hot docs donde por cierto
mi marca extraordinaria favorita esté en
medio y es mi esposa que me acompaña
desde hace 15 años desde hace 15 años
ella cree en lo que nosotros estamos
desarrollando en lo que estamos haciendo
y por último no me voy sin recordarles
todo esto con una frase las marcas
extraordinarias requieren compromisos
extraordinarios muchas gracias
[Aplausos]